john roberts mentioned earlier South
Carolina Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham had a long meeting with President
Trump at the White House yesterday about
the crisis in northeastern Syria and
other matters he joins us tonight live
from Washington senator thanks welcome
back to Spanky
well tell us about that meeting we
understand from reporting that you were
talking about the situation there was a
call that you were also a part of with
President Erdogan yeah there's a call to
President Erdogan and Maslin the leader
the Kurdish forces that helped us
destroy Isis the first thing I learned
is that President Trump did not give her
one or green light I would urge
President Trump to release to the public
the letter he sent to Irwin urging him
not to invade Syria it was a very good
letter the president did not wake up one
day and tell her one you can have Syria
her one went into Syria against
president Trump's advice and counseling
and now scepter president Trump and the
rest of us to fix it but I blame or the
one not Trump okay but isn't it implied
that there was a green light if the
force leave the Kurdish forces on the
ground and it opens the door for the
Turks to come in it was a mistake I
think not to push back Carter but the
president sent a letter to Iran that was
really a good letter imploring him not
to create a problem here we were working
with the legitimate concerns of Turkey
about YPG elements they consider to be a
terrorist group they have legitimate
concerns but the solution is not turkey
invading Syria allowing Isis to come
back and Iran to be the biggest winner
so what I hope will happen is that the
relationship with Turkey is hanging by a
thread is valuable it's worth salvaging
if I were a president earlier on I would
listen vice president Pence I would have
a ceasefire right now and try to put
this thing back together before the
Kurds who we've stood by and who we owe
a debt to are hurt even more and if
there's any incursion into kobani or
around kobani by the Turkish military
any massacres of Trustees we're going to
hold our one personally accountable we
you mentioned kobani it's a town in
right here in Syria
the significance of that that's sort of
the Washington DC for the Kurds now who
are the Kurds these are Syrian Kurds who
helped us destroy Isis there were 60,000
arabs mostly kurds that went into Raqqa
and took the Caliphate down by a ground
action we provided Special Forces
assistance and air cover but they died
by the thousands we owe it to them not
to abandon them if we abandon the Kurds
and they have to fight Turkey these
10,000 Isis fighters are going to break
loose and that will be on president
Trump's watch it would be a nightmare
for the country and him if we can get
turkey to stop get them out of Syria we
can protect the Turkish interests
between the Kurds and Turkey and we can
keep Iran from coming in what I worry
about the most right now tonight is Iran
is about to move in to northeastern
Syria and take over the oil fields and
that would be a great boost for the
Iranian economy and I'm urging President
Trump to send some military American
military personnel to the northeastern
Syrian oil fields to protect it from an
Iranian takeover well so let me just get
this straight you're supporting
President Trump but you don't like how
this happened or how the process
happened right you like the letter that
he sent but not how this all unfolded I
think it's fair criticism for about two
years president Trump has been trying to
create a safe zone and I've been working
with him to keep about the Kurds away
from the Turkish border and Turkey away
from the Kurds that helped us to destroy
Isis rwan destroyed that he lied to me
two weeks ago he ignored the president's
counsel he's into Syria now and it is
going to create a comeback for Isis
because the Kurds can't fight turkey and
watch the Isis fighters the 10,000 it's
going to create an opening for a rhyme
to come in the Kurds cannot align with
Assad that's all like aligning with Iran
so I blame Turkey but I'm looking to
president Trump to fix this he's got a
good plan I hope early one will listen
to the vice president I want a good
relationship with Turkey but I'm going
to introduce sanctions next two days
from now with Democrats that would hit
turkey hard and I applaud President
Trump sanctions against Turkey they're
really tough and they're not coming
until turkey stops this war you know
there's another Republican senator who
supports the president but in a
different way he supports the end to
endless wars that his Senator Rand Paul
take a listen
Lindsey perhaps been wrong about almost
every foreign policy decision of the
last two decades he was wrong about the
Iraq war the Iraq war was a mistake and
made Iran stronger allowed more chaos
more instability and more terrorism he
was wrong about the war in Libya it led
to more chaos and more terrorism he's
wrong about this Senator Paul was
obviously asked about your comments
about this but just forget about general
Paul in general Graham how about
listening to actual generals I've been
to Iraq and Afghanistan 56 times I've
been to Syria twice since last year I
think I have an informed opinion but
forget about me our military is telling
President Trump if we abandon the Kurds
nobody will help us in the future
without the Kurds Raqqa would still be
occupied by Isis if we give the
oilfields to Iran it will undercut our
maximum pressure campaign Senator Paul
is an avowed libertarian I respect this
point of view but I think it's dangerous
if we abandoned the Kurds who's going to
help us in the future and the last thing
we want is another front against Israel
Israel is worried as I speak tonight
about Iran coming into Syria and getting
the oil fields and being more powerful I
want to ask you two more things one is
did you hear the hunter Biden interview
or pieces of it and what did you make of
his kind of explanation for I made a
mistake on the appearances but didn't do
anything wrong and he knows he gets jobs
because his name is Bohdan
well I think this is a defining moment
in the Biden campaign Joe Biden is truly
a friend he's lost two children and a
wife I guess three children now he's had
a tried tragic life I think he's a good
man but what hunter Biden did was wrong
at every level if the Republican had
done the same thing it'd be front-page
news all over the world
I've asked Rudy Giuliani to come before
our Senate Judiciary Committee to talk
about corruption in the Ukraine and if
he does come and he does tell us then
we'll look at my subpoenas
well that's up to Ruud he says he's
gonna ignore the subpoenas on the house
here's what I think I think what hunter
Biden did does not pass the smell test
it should be looked at when Horowitz
tells us about the FISA warrant and the
counter tillage its investigation
against the Trump campaign I hope
somebody will pay attention all right
one last question that is about former
national security advisor John Bolton in
New York Times says mr. Bolton got into
a tense exchange on July 10th with
Gordon Sunderland who was working with
Rudy Giuliani to press Ukraine to
investigate Democrats I'm not a part of
whatever drug deal someone and Mulvaney
are cooking out mr. Bolten told miss
Hill who testified Giuliani is a
hand-grenade who's going to blow
everybody up this hill quoted mr. Bolton
is saying during an earlier conversation
what do you make of this and all the
testimony that's happening on Capitol
Hill you know I really don't know what
Rudy was up to but I think it was
legitimate for President Trump to raise
corruption in the Ukraine with the newly
elected Ukrainian president we give him
like four hundred million dollars the
transcript of the phone call I am okay
with a matter of fact I thought it was
an excellent phone call by President
Trump and I want to say this to Speaker
of the House Pelosi
if you impeach President Trump based on
this phone call transcript it is dead on
arrival in the Senate I'm trying to get
a letter together with Republican
senators telling Speaker Pelosi that any
impeachment article based on this phone
call will not fly the Senate look at
what Rudy did but I've seen no evidence
at all that President Trump has done
anything wrong
so to Lindsey Graham in Washington
senator thanks for the time thank you